well well well people of the internet so
the rumors were actually true a Harry
Potter TV series retelling the original
Seven book story is official it's
happening and I have to say it looks
like the vast majority of Potter fans
are not happy at least not from the
reaction I have seen online you guys are
freaking out out there right now
you know it's the Internet it's
understandable there's going to be a lot
of panic and personally I think it's a
little bit too much for reasons that
I'll explain here shortly now I know
guys this is a series near and dear to
many of you out there as it is to me
frankly that's why we care so much and
why the reactions are usually so strong
so trust me I get where you're coming
from it's because you care it's because
you love this world and you don't want
to see them mess it up however I'm just
gonna walk through a few of the
critiques and a few of the problems that
I've seen from people so far and then
talk to you about why I think maybe
they're not valid or maybe why I think
you should look at it with more of a
glass half full than a glass half empty
approach so one of the first critiques
I've seen is is that it's only been 10
years since the last movie well it's
actually been a little bit more than
that it was 2011 for Deathly Hallows
Part 2. however if you think about the
first film it debuted all the way back
in 2001. so when I think of it like that
I mean it's been more than 20 years
since we told this first story the story
of the Philosopher's Stone or source for
stone depending on where you live so
when it comes to that story I definitely
think that enough time has passed now
the next concern I see is that a lot of
people say the movies are already so
well done and that you don't need to
redo it they were already so good and I
agree the movies were good but I think
there may be a little bit of
rose-colored glasses a little bit of
nostalgia it's kind of slipping in here
because guys I read the books before the
movies I know there's not a lot of
people out there who can say that I mean
you had to be born at just the right
time to be in on this before it kind of
just exploded into what it is today
Harry Potter and the Goblet of Fire the
book was released in July of 2000 so
four books were out before the first
movie ever happened so I had read all
four of those before that first movie
came out and there were a lot of fan
expectations going in and I'll be honest
with you man I was one of those people
who was critiquing every little thing
right I was a kid so it was just like oh
my gosh they changed this they changed
that nitpicking all the little things
but as I grew up over time I learned to
appreciate the movies for what they were
they weren't meant to be an exact word
for word beat by beat copy of the books
that's not just what movies are and
again I was young at the time but now
I've learned it was a retelling of that
story and so by and large I feel like
the movies did a good job but I don't
think they were perfect there were a lot
of things that they left out guys a lot
of things that they changed maybe people
haven't read the books recently so some
of these things they've forgotten and
it's almost like the movies are sort of
your more dominant memory but just
thinking off the top of my head here as
I Was preparing this video here just a
few I thought of first of all Ron's
character Ron's character was completely
changed now I'm not talking about Rupert
Grint I'm talking about the portrayal of
Ron the dialogue everything they gave
Ron in the movie very very different
from bookron in fact it was kind of a
joke in the fandom is that they gave a
lot of Ron's lines actually to Hermione
because she's kind of like the source of
all information in the movies but Ron
was way more of a strong character in
the books whereas in the movies he kind
of just ended up being relegated to this
comic relief character instead so I see
this as a great opportunity to actually
showcase the book version of Ron and how
strong of a character he really was
Dumbledore oh my gosh how can we forget
Dumbledore and calmly
right I mean this one you have to
consider they did change actors
unfortunately due to Richard Harris's
death something that they did not
anticipate and Michael gambin really
came in and just played a completely
different version of Dumbledore now I
don't know how much of it was on him how
much of it was on the direction that he
got but for me personally he just never
became Dumbledore for me he didn't have
that same kind of Twinkle in his eye
that Richard Harris did now I know a lot
of people also say Richard Harris may
not have been able to do some of the
scenes that gamble was able to do but I
feel like there's gotta be kind of a
happy medium in there I also wasn't a
huge fan of the end of movie five if you
go back and read the scene read the
battle between Dumbledore and Voldemort
at the end of Order of the Phoenix and
then watch the movie the effects in the
movie were great they were fantastic but
the way that battle played out I thought
the movie made Dumbledore look so weak
like he was struggling through that
whole battle you go and read that book
Dumbledore is just chill man he is in
total control of that situation not
panicking whatsoever until Voldemort
starts messing around in Harry's mind
and that's when Dumbledore knows okay
this is really serious at this point
didn't you have like Harry and Jenny's
relationship which I mean the movie's
just completely mishandled that in my
opinion The Marauder storyline it's not
even there in the movies the gaunt
family and Voldemort's past there's so
much more that they can do there you've
got winky you've got spew you've got
peeves who wasn't in the movie at all I
mean how can we forget the Quidditch
World Cup which apparently enough didn't
even happen in that game for them to
show it in the movie we just get the
nice little intro sequence and that was
it the third task completely changed
from the book The End Of Deathly Hallows
that honestly may be some of my biggest
complaints is the way that battle plays
out in the movie it was like all about
for special effects you know they wanted
just that bombastic ending which you
have an incredible ending in the books
and they just completely changed I mean
we have this weird like Voldemort and
Harry tackling each other just flying
through the air something weird going on
with their faces they're like trying to
choke each other what was that anyway
the final battle between the two doesn't
even take place in the great hall and
then when Harry defeats Voldemort he
doesn't crumple to the floor he kind of
just vanishes like he's somehow special
whereas that was such a huge focus in
the book is that he died like a man
because he was in fact just a normal
human there was nothing special about
him okay I'm done I promise I'm done but
you guys hopefully you get the point
there was a lot of things that changed
and again I say this as someone who
enjoyed the movies I don't want you to
think I'm just totally hating on them
there but when I see so many people
online saying they were perfect they
were not perfect they were really good
they certainly helped with cultural
phenomenon and just the explosion of
Harry Potter being what it is but they
were not perfect the other big critique
I keep seeing is that you can't replace
the actors and actresses it's like Dan
is Harry Rupert is Ron Hermione is Emma
and then very tragically we have all the
actors and actresses who have passed
away such as Richard Harris such as Alan
Rickman Richard Griffiths and I agree
here these were iconic portrayals they
were but here's the thing the TV series
is not going to replace the movies it's
not like the movies are just erased from
the earth and now this is the definitive
story that's not what it is you can
always go back and watch the movies
anytime nothing is going to replace
those stories nothing is going to
replace those actors they will always
still be there just as the book will
still always be there and again for
those of us who read the book before the
movies we had to get used to this too
because it's almost like you have to
treat it as a separate thing yes it is
all part of the same world but it is a
retelling of that story I have the book
version of the Harry Potter Universe in
my mind and I have the movie version of
the Harry Potter Universe in my mind the
the book version is still the one that I
vastly vastly prefer who knows when this
one comes out maybe I'll prefer it to
the movies maybe I won't maybe I'll
prefer the movies and say they actually
did it better but I do think this kind
of extreme instant reaction of no it
can't possibly be better it's just over
the top I think it can does it have a
very tall order absolutely and that
leads us directly into one of the
reasons I'm excited about this is
because it is TV rather than a movie I
mean one of the biggest problems and one
of the biggest issues that movies have
is when you're adapting these books you
almost have to cut so much just for the
sake of Time Movie 1 and movie two are
very faithful adaptations I would say so
personally I think the first two seasons
of this show are going to be the most
fascinating to see because the movies
even for those of us who were really
really critical those first two actually
did a pretty good job in terms of being
accurate to the source material I feel
like movie three and then especially
movie four because that's when the books
just got so big they had to start
cutting out so many things and
truncating a lot of story lines even
cutting out certain characters entirely
that's when I really think you'll get to
see the strength of telling this in the
form of a TV show rather than a movie
and also guys it's HBO they have a
really really good track record I mean
some of the best TV out there right now
is on HBO all right now to be totally
fair to you guys would I prefer
something different this is where I
probably agree with you guys because I
think I would have preferred something
different they could have told the story
of the Marauders of the founders story
about completely new witches in Wizards
set in a completely different time
period of course there was that rumor of
a TV series based around Hogwarts Legacy
to be honest I'm still not sure that
that is out of the question who knows
maybe that's still a possibility as
something that they could introduce in
addition to this Harry Potter TV series
and of all the criticisms that I've seen
out there to me this one is the one that
is the most valid because the world
itself is so rich there is so much there
and as we've just seen with Hogwarts
Legacy there is so much that you can
tell in this world so many different
stories I think a lot of fans would have
preferred them taking a chance on that
rather than retelling this story again
that we all know so well already now I'm
not saying I agree with this next part
here but I do think the rationalization
of it when you think about it from wb's
perspective goes something like this
look at Fantastic Beasts that was
something said in a different time
period with a few characters you know
that we knew from the main series but it
did not perform the way they were hoping
cursed child at least in terms of the
story was rough I think everyone would
agree with that personally I haven't
seen the play but I have heard from a
lot of people who have that as a play
it's actually pretty good it's enjoyable
so I think From wb's perspective they're
probably seeing this as look we tried
with Fantastic Beasts and for whatever
reason it didn't work I think a lot of
fans might have some thoughts on why it
didn't work and maybe they're making the
wrong conclusions from that failure and
then I have to be honest before cursed
child I absolutely wanted more Harry
Potter I wanted to see what things were
like for him as an adult even though I
thought his story ended in a very clear
conclusive way I mean how awesome would
a series have been just like about Harry
and Ron's Adventures as aurors each book
or HTV series or each movie could have
just been like a case that they're going
on and solving very straightforward you
don't have to do anything super crazy
but then instead we got something like
cursed child which just made so many
egregious mistakes in my opinion again
as a fan when it comes to the story when
it comes to the established lore that I
personally just take issue with so maybe
it's a good thing that they aren't
trying to do that and just tell a
completely different story with these
same characters again they're saying
okay look you know what it's already
such a great story we know the books are
great the movies were pretty good too
that being said they had to leave out a
lot because of the sheer fact that they
were movies and not a TV series let's
see if we can retell this story again as
a television series with more time with
a completely new cast and see if we
actually may be able to improve upon it
and as they have said in their releases
introduce it to a new generation of
Wizarding World fans and that overall
World part is one of the things that I
am most fascinated to see I mean will
they reuse Hogwarts will they reuse some
of the sets or will it be just
completely different will they want a
totally new look at all of this so my
main message here guys is just take a
step back take a deep breath Don't Panic
even if it ends up bad we still have the
books and we still have the original
movies that's it could we end up
something better maybe so I'm gonna
choose to be optimistic I'm going to
choose to be excited and wait to see
more information but with the success of
Hogwarts Legacy and hopefully with the
success of this maybe that could lead to
further stories maybe that could lead to
all those other things that we want to
see in this world that maybe they're a
little hesitant to try right now maybe
that could one day happen I mean now
since I mentioned the idea of Harry and
Ron as orders going out on little
adventures I can't get that out of my
head I want to see that show who knows
maybe one day but sound off in the
comments guys I know you will try to
keep it civil as always thank you all so
much for watching I'll talk to you again
soon